طالبان وضعت افغانستان على شفا كارثه
انسانيه فبقررها منع المراه من التعليم
الجامعي لم توجه طالبان ضربه لحقوق المراه
فحسن بل وضعت كل قطاع التعليم الجامعي في
خطر الامر كذلك بالنسبه لمنع عمل النساء
في المنظمات الانسانيه الحركه هددت بذلك
حياه شعب كامل يعيش اغلبه على المساعدات
للبقاء على قيد الحياه الامر لم يعد يتوقف
على المراه بل المجتمع باكمله في التحركات
الداخليه بينما اتساعت دائره استقالات
الاساتذه الجامعيين ترد على قرار طالبان
زادت ايضا نسبه الطلاب الذكور المقاطعين
للمحاضرات للامتحانات تضامنا مع زميلاتهم
فيما اغلقت جامعات ابوابها بالكامل بينها
جامعه موره في كابول وبتت ربع الجامعات
الخاصه في افغانستان تواجه خطر الاغلاق
على الطالبه المتحدثه باسم اتحاد الجامعات
الخاصه قال ان 35 مؤسسه تعليميه معرضه
للاغلاق
يوجد في افغانستان 140 جامعه خاصه في 24
مقاطعه تضم حواليه 200 الف طالب بينهم نحو
70 الف طالبه
وتوظف الجامعات حوالي خمس 22 الف شخص
هؤلاء مهددون بخساره وظائفهم الان